كريم بنزيما لاعب كره قدم فرنسي وثاني
هدافي نادي ريال مدريد واليوم راح تكون
مباراه الاخيره مع النادي من بعد 14 سنه
فنادي ريال مدريد اعلن في بيان رسمي عن
اتفاق بين النادي وبين بنزيما لانهاء
مسيرته اللي وصفها البيان بالرائعه
واستعرض البيان انجازات بنزيما من وقت
انضمامه للنادي في 2009 خلال المواسم ال14
اللي شارك فيها واللي فاز خلالها النادي ب
25 لقب وعدد من الجوائز من بينها جائزه
الكره الذهبيه وهو خامس اكثر لاعب مشاركه
بالمباريات في النادي مع
647 مباراه وثاني هداف تاريخي بريال مدريد
بعد رونالدو برصيد اهداف
353 هدف
وتابع البيان انه بنزيما اليوم بيمتلك حق
تقرير مستقبله وانه ريال مدريد منزله
وتمنوا التوفيق في المرحله الجديده من
حياته كمان انه الثلاثاء رح يكون في حفل
وداع بحضور رئيس النادي ومن وقت ما طلع
هذا البيان واسم بنزيما طبعا ترند رقم اول
حول حول العالم وفي السعوديه ايضا تحديدا
والسبب هي الاخبار اللي بتتداولها وسائل
اعلام من ايام واللي الان صارت بتقول انها
اقرب للحقيقه مع نهايه مسيره بنزيما مع
الريال بنتكلم عن اخبار انضمامهم الى نادي
الاتحاد لعقد يمتد لموسمين وزي ما ذكرت
مشاهدينا بنزيما كمان اسمه ترند حول
العالم وسبب طبعا يعني قصه الرحيل عن ريال
مدريد والعقل وما الى ذلك وطبعا هو قتلوه
مع النادي صولات وجولات وطبيعي يكون في
كثير حديث عنه خاصه من مشجعي النادي
الاخبار كلها للان متناقله عن وسائل اعلام
ما في عليها اي تاكيد لا من النادي
ولا من بنزيما نفسه نحن هنا طبعا بنتكلم
عن النادي الاتحاد وبنزيما لكن اللي مؤكد
عندنا الان عن مصادر مطلعه هو انه رئيس
الاتحاد ونائبه ووصلوا مدريد من شويه من
اسباب الزياره ما احد اعلن عنها ولكن
وسائل الاعلام بتقول انهم هناك يعني
للتوقيع على صفقه انتقال بنزيما
للنادي وبما اننا بنتكلم عن الكوره
والدوري السعودي وانضمام لاعبين كمان
عالميين لوفي لازم نقول انه مو بس بنزيما
اللي اسمه ترند في السعوديه فماسي كمان
ومن ايام اسمه واخباره ترند وبرضو في
تقارير انه في طريقه للتعاقد مع نادي
سعودي وتحديدا الاسم المتداول هو الهلال
والترند زاد اكثر واكثر مع اعلان نادي
باريس سان جيرمان عن انتهاء عقد ميسي بعد
موسمين واتمنى له التوفيق في مسيرته
الاحترافيه